frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren wir begrüßen
ausdrücklich dass Sie Herr Bundeskanzler
vor dem letzten Europäischen Rat in
diesem Jahr und auch vor dem ersten
eu-asien-gipfel heute eine
Regierungserklärung vor dem Deutschen
Bundestag abgeben wir teilen ihre
Einschätzung des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine und
vor allem ihre Bewertung der Entwicklung
dieses Krieges in den letzten Wochen das
russische Regime unter Präsident Putin
verübt mit den gezielten Angriffen gegen
die Infrastruktur des Landes
gegen die Wohnbezirke gegen Kinderheime
gegen Krankenhäuser und Altenheime
schwerste Kriegsverbrechen für die Putin
und seine Stärken eines Tages von der
Weltgemeinschaft zur Rechenschaft
gezogen ist
wir stimmen ihnen zu Herr Bundeskanzler
dass die Europäische Union und die NATO
in den Wochen und Monaten seit dem
Beginn dieses Krieges am 24 Februar
zusammengewachsen sind und sich als
handlungsfähig erwiesen haben
Putin und sein verbrecherisches Regime
haben vor allem die
Widerstandsfähigkeit der Ukraine die
Standhaftigkeit ihrer Regierung unter
Präsident Zielinski die
Opferbereitschaft und die
Leidensfähigkeit ihrer Bevölkerung und
auch die Einsatzfähigkeit und Kampfkraft
der Armee vollkommen unterschätzt
wir können uns zum Ende dieses wie sie
es gesagt haben besonders schweren
Jahres Herr Bundeskanzler wir können zum
Ende dieses Jahres dem ukrainischen Volk
nur mit großem Respekt unsere
Anerkennung und auch unsere Anteilnahme
an ihrem Schicksal aussprechen
zum Ende
zum Ende des Jahres trauern die Familien
in der Ukraine um viele tausend
Gefallene und verwundete Soldaten um
viele tausend getötete Kinder junge und
ältere Menschen unschuldige Männer und
Frauen die diesen Kriegsverbrechen zum
Opfer gefallen sind und wenn wir meine
Damen und Herren in wenigen Tagen unser
Weihnachtsfest feiern dann sind in
unserem Land in dem wir doch das große
Glück haben in Frieden und Freiheit zu
leben dann sind unsere Gedanken auch bei
den Menschen in der Ukraine die
unvorstellbares Leid und unvorstellbare
not in diesen Tagen aushalten müssen
den Winter
dem Land steht im Winter
dem Land steht im Winter weiterhin
schwere Wochen und Monate bevor es ist
deshalb wichtig dass wir unsere
Unterstützung und Hilfsbereitschaft auch
erneut unterstreichen und darin nicht
nachlassen das gilt für die humanitäre
und finanzielle Hilfe das gilt aber auch
für die militärische Hilfe und anders
als der eine oder andere in diesem Haus
und außerhalb meint sagen und denken zu
müssen verlängert unsere Hilfe diesen
Krieg nicht das Gegenteil ist richtig je
mehr wir helfen je mehr wir helfen umso
schneller ist dieser Krieg vorüber und
deshalb Herr Bundeskanzler bleiben wir
dabei ja Deutschland hat nach langem
Zögern einiges an wichtigem
militärischen Gerät geliefert aber nach
wie vor fehlen der ukrainischen Armee
Schützenpanzer und Kampfpanzer die wir
aus unseren Beständen und aus Beständen
der Industrie liefern können
auch fast zehn Monate nach Beginn dieses
Krieges verstehen sie sich Herr
Bundeskanzler verstecken sie sich immer
noch hinter den NATO-Partnern die
angeblich auch nicht liefern wollen wir
wissen mittlerweile dass dies falsch ist
es liegt vor allem an Ihnen ganz
persönlich dass die Ukraine diese Hilfe
nicht gebracht
sie haben in ihrer Rede gesagt wir haben
in Deutschland hier unsere
Verteidigungspolitik neu ausgerichtet
Herr Bundeskanzler das
bemerken die Nato-Partner und die
Europäische Union anders sie bleiben
weit hinter den Zusagen zurück die sie
von dieser Stelle aus am 27 februar in
ihrer Regierungserklärung gegeben haben
der Verteidigungsetat der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland singt und wenn wir viel
Glück haben dann wird heute im Laufe des
Tages der erste Beschluss des
Haushaltsausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages getroffen aus diesen 100
Milliarden Euro nun die ersten Mittel
freizugeben zehn Monate nach dem Beginn
des Krieges mehr als ein halbes Jahr
nachdem wir hier unter großen Zeitdruck
der von ihnen gesetzt worden ist die
Änderung des Grundgesetzes beschlossen
haben diese Einschätzung die sie hier
abgegeben haben stimmt nicht mit der
Wirklichkeit
sie haben in ihrer Regierungserklärung
Herr Bundeskanzler die wichtige
Zusammenarbeit innerhalb der
Europäischen Union angesprochen und
natürlich wir teilen diese Einschätzung
auch in dieser Frage mit ihnen aber so
wortreich und gut funktionieren sie
diese Zusammenarbeit dargestellt haben
es ist doch nicht zu übersehen dass wir
zurzeit eine tiefe Störung des
deutsch-französischen Verhältnisses
erleben sehr viele Beobachter in Berlin
und vor allem in Paris sprechen von
einem Tiefpunkt der Beziehungen und es
war der französische Staatspräsident der
Ihnen am Rande des letzten Gipfels in
Brüssel gesagt hat wörtlich es ist nicht
gut wenn sich Deutschland isoliert und
der
tagesspiegelt heute
Einzelgänger in der EU-Politik Herr
Bundeskanzler das ist die Wahrnehmung
anderer außerhalb ihrer Regierung und
ich füge eine Bemerkung hinzu
da sie noch einmal Bezug genommen haben
auf ihre Rede die sie im August im
Sommer in Prag an der Karls-Universität
gehalten haben sie haben in dieser Rede
Frankreich die deutsch-französischen
Beziehungen die gemeinsame
Gründungsgeschichte in der Europäischen
Union und die deutsch-französische
Freundschaft als einem der wichtigsten
Pfeiler der EU-Politik mit keinem
einzigen Wort erwähnt das mag vielleicht
in ihrer Regierung niemand bemerkt haben
aber in Paris ist das mit größter
Aufmerksamkeit wahrgenommen worden und
das ist die Realität ihrer Europa
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben heute eine ganze Liste von
Themen gehört von ihnen die sie genannt
haben was jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
weiter zu geschehen hat ich finde es
einmal so sagen sie Listen wie ein guter
Anwalt
akribisch das Inventar auf dass ich in
dem Haus befindet dass wir gemeinsam
bewohnen aber ihnen fehlt fast völlig
der Blick für die Statik dieses Hauses
für das Fundament dieses Hauses und
Ihnen fehlt die Fantasie eines
Architekten und der entschlossene Wille
eines Baumeisters dieses Haus in Europa
jetzt wetterfest und zukunftsfähig zu
machen und vielleicht in diesem Haus in
Europa sogar einen neuen Teil zu bauen
und wenn sie jetzt so dazwischen rufen
dann will ich Ihnen drei konkrete
Beispiele nennen über die wir heute
morgen eigentlich auch sprechen müssten
sie haben über die
deutsch-amerikanischen die europäische
amerikanischen Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
gesprochen was
Stellen aus dieser Beschreibung die sie
heute morgen abgegeben haben heißt das
im Klartext dass sie und sie die SPD und
die Grünen
jetzt kommen ausverhandelt wird ja oder
nein meine Damen und Herren sie haben
hier über
gesprochen und über die
unabhängiger zu machen von China sie
treffen sich richtigerweise mit den
aseanstaaten jetzt in Brüssel was heißt
das denn konkret etwa im Hinblick auf
die Handelsbeziehungen zu Südamerika
sind sie jetzt dafür dass das Merkur
surabkommen das ausverhandelt ist mit
den südamerikanischen Staaten sind Sie
dafür dass das ratifiziert und
verabschiedet wird als ein neues
Freihandels kommen zwischen der
Europäischen Union und der
merkt starken
und dann muss ich Ihnen sagen der
Bundeskanzler das hat mich nun wirklich
fast
entsetzt sie geben in ihrer
Regierungserklärung ich bin gespannt ob
sie gleich immer noch so reagieren ist
Ihnen eigentlich aufgefallen dass der
Bundeskanzler in seiner
Regierungserklärung nicht ein einziges
Wort zu den Vorgängen im Iran gesagt hat
meine Damen und Herren in diesem Land
werden seit
drei auf offener Straße Demonstranten
erschossen dieses Land versorgt die
Hisbollah und die Hamas mit den
finanziellen Mitteln die diesen Terror
überhaupt erst möglich macht dieses Land
finanziert die Drohnen die Russland
einsetzt gegen die Zivilbevölkerung in
der Ukraine und sie erwähnen dieses Land
mit keinem einzigen Wort Herr
Bundeskanzler es wäre doch richtig
gewesen am heutigen Morgen zu sagen dass
sie sich dafür einsetzen dass dieses
Land jetzt vollkommen isoliert wird und
das von Deutschland aus eine Initiative
ausgeht die dieses Land Iran jetzt so zu
isolieren dass es keine Chance mehr hat
diesen internationalen Terrorismus zu
finanzieren warum
warum geben sie uns
in der Befragung ihrer Regierung
keine Antwort auf die Frage ob sie sich
bei diesem Gipfel der jetzt in Brüssel
stattfindet dafür einsetzen diese
sogenannten revolutionsgarten die die
Stütze des Regimes sind als eine
Terrororganisation einzustufen warum
bekommen wir noch nicht einmal eine
Antwort von ihrer Regierung wenn wir
Ihnen diese Frage stellen ja oder nein
Herr Bundeskanzler
ihre Regierungserklärung enthält viel
Richtiges keine Frage mit dem wir
einverstanden sind und was wir
selbstverständlich aus Überzeugung auch
mitverantworten wollen aber es fällt
doch auf das ganz wesentliche Teile
fehlen und dass sie vor allem den Fragen
gezielt aus dem Wege gehen die in ihrer
Regierung offenkundig streitig sind auf
die das stärkste und
bevölkerungsreichste Land der
Europäischen Union aber eigentlich
gerade zum Abschluss des Jahres 2022
eine Antwort geben müsste Herr
Bundeskanzler diese Antworten bleiben
sie und Schuld